la guerra en afganistán se ha acabado
con esta frase el presidente joe biden
defendió la retirada de las tropas de
coalición
argumentando que la decisión era irse o
escalar la guerra más larga de eeuu en
suelo extranjero y que él mismo calificó
como eterna
soy el cuarto presidente que ha
enfrentado
el tema de cuándo y cómo terminar esta
guerra después de 20 años de guerra en
afganistán me niego a mandar otra
generación de hijos e hijas
estadounidenses a luchar el presidente
también alabó la caótica misión a
contrarreloj en la que se embarcaron sus
tropas desde hace dos semanas cuando los
talibanes llegaron a kabul y volvieron a
recuperar el control del gobierno 120
mil personas entre estadounidenses y
afganos fueron evacuados desde entonces
pero también lamentó las pérdidas
humanas especialmente los 13 militares
que murieron el pasado 26 de agosto tras
un ataque perpetrado por un grupo aliado
del estado islámico a ellos y a
cualquier potencial enemigo by then
envió un contundente mensaje
y si es que yo le quiero decir no
estamos hemos acabado con ustedes
todavía aquellos que quisieran que
quiere desearle el mal eeuu aquellos que
están entrando en prácticas terroristas
en contra de nosotros nuestros aliados
sepan estos estados unidos jamás
descansará quien jamás perdonará que
jamás olvidará
nos casaremos hasta el final
y haremos que pague en el último precio
by the reiteró que seguirá apoyando al
pueblo afgano a través de la diplomacia
la influencia internacional y la ayuda
humanitaria y así acabar con la
violencia y garantizar los derechos
especialmente de las mujeres y niñas
afganas un mensaje que deja claro que la
incursión militar acabó pero que los
ojos estadounidenses siguen sobre
afganistán